it's like that for your break never
happened except where's the screaming
stampede for years on perhaps the fans
to have grown up but when the door is
open there's the same old rush for the
best seats in the house
the band are taking their latest album
kings of suburbia on the road it
features only English lyrics and King
bill gets the show started with we found
us
the van purposely chose smaller club
venues for their long-awaited tour I
think I'm lost among the atmosphere is
totally different to a big arena but
it's still high production because we
wanted to give the venues a nightclub
feel the live clips in and knock lafave
and in vivo design like nothing we'd
wanted to do for ages originally for the
previous album this time around we make
concrete plans for the concept tour
before they release these a concept to a
good plan the house is rockin and so is
the pup export camera
the club gigs are also a kind of dress
rehearsal for the tour of major arenas
they will be doing later in the year
those on stage effects don't come cheap
and neither do the tickets at around 90
euros
yeah loiter that we're always being
asked whether we actually make any money
from tours because of all the production
well I personally expect that kind of
show we've never been singer-songwriter
types sitting on stools and strumming
away on our guitars for us it's a show
and the visuals are just as important
elephants canals or vista cialis and
ever the band came under fire in the
german media for charging up to eighteen
hundred euros for a meet and greet
package for two but the singers have got
used to criticism over the years
sometimes I still think why are we so
popular with people who write that stuff
about us or can't they pick on someone
else for once but you get used to it no
damn government these numbers and under
these fans and France haven't been
turned off by the prices some have been
camped out since four in the morning for
a ticket but queuing for hours as part
of the experience they said we've been
fans for seven years we used to follow
them everywhere but we're adults now we
grew up to know we love the new song
almost the same as me
shabba I learned German thanks to Tokyo
hotel oh yeah that's dunk Tokyo tell I
love Tom
in the age of smartphones and social
media the band know every move they make
will come under extreme scrutiny
especially after a four year hiatus
it's matt and a half no booze and mature
like this can make you more nervous
themelis can go wrong on stage in
Argentina I fell over and it's on
YouTube it's incredible how fast things
happen and that can also up the pressure
of it but you have to free yourself from
that discutir does I'm guys that is much
my visa missing after from famous their
faithful fans in Paris love the new show
but later in the year tokio hotel will
have to show that they can still cut it
at the big arenas to
Oh